in X-Men Days of Future Past Evan Peters
was filmed running on a treadmill in
front of a green screen so he could then
be placed into these Frozen shots which
were filmed at over 3 000 frames per
second on set these actors and objects
were stabilized with wires and poles but
these ingredients in this spilling soup
were all added with CG Frozen in Time
sequences have come a long way thanks to
advancements in technology and CGI just
look at this time freeze scene in the
Twilight Zone Yeah Boy come on without
CG it was difficult for director Douglas
Hayes to hide subtle Motions like
breathing and shaking so he found that
the best way to cover up these
unavoidable errors was to keep moving
the camera so viewers didn't even have
time to notice the movement trick is
still used today but modern cameras also
allow filmmakers to slow down the
visuals by changing the frame rates most
modern movies are shot at 24 frames per
second if you increase the frame rate
more images are produced allowing
filmmakers to stretch out and slow the
scene down frame by frame so for example
this moment in 1999's The Matrix
the camera was actually running at 96
frames per second and to capture
Quicksilver time in Days of Future Past
and apocalypse the X-Men team used a
phantom camera capable of both filming 3
000 frames per second and moving at 90
miles per hour so an action that
happened in just one second in real time
could be extended to 15 seconds VFX
artists can also read time a live action
shot a technique that was required to
make Quicksilver look like he was moving
faster than his environment that meant
rotoscoping the actor out of the
original shot frame by frame then
filming him in front of a green screen
so he could be re-timed separately
before adding him back in
filling these scenes with various Frozen
characters and background elements can
be done both practically and with visual
effects and not everything in the
Quicksilver scenes was VFX just look at
these dishes propped up by wires and
poles
often practical effects in combination
with CG touch-ups can add even more
realism like in 2021's the worst person
in the world
which leaned heavily into the Practical
side for this scene in which the world
freezes around the protagonist Julie
director joham Trier made a creative
choice to do most of the films Frozen in
Time effects in camera much of this was
achieved through the clever
craftsmanship of prop Master hedaviric
when it works it works and creates a
magic onset that everyone is just very
excited to be a part of like when Axel
freezes in the middle of pouring coffee
to create this effect had a studied
photos of real coffee streams and
sculpted a replica using polymer clay
it's not just one line of coffee it's
water and water Frozen time is always
unique and you get those little
beautiful lines down that sculpt was
used as the basis for a negative cast
which he poured resin into to add color
so you really want that see-through like
Lush coffee there was also real coffee
in the pot to get the movement before
and after the Frozen sequence so to keep
the real coffee from spilling Heather
covered the pot's opening with ultra
clear tape and the resin dream was
rigged to a coffee cup with a flexible
wire so it could be repositioned on set
while items like the coffee stream
needed to be made from scratch others
just needed some clever modifications to
appear Frozen
like these headphones which were taped
to this extra shirt to maintain their
shape sometimes the real thing works as
long as there's no wind similarly how to
use tape and metal wire on a real
briefcase so it wouldn't flap inanimate
objects are one challenge but keeping
everything in place gets even more
difficult when you're dealing with
living breathing creatures animals are
very difficult to convince and to get
them to do what you want and I don't
know any animal that just wants to stand
still and do nothing so these two dogs
in the background are completely fake
but the fake pups needed to be placed in
unique and dynamic ways so they wouldn't
just look like stuffed animals that
included breaking one of the stuffed
legs like he's doing a little little
strut and holding them down with rocks
so they wouldn't fall over human actors
can stand still on command but
maintaining certain positions for long
periods of time still requires some
extra distance and can be painful and
uncomfortable and we were at each
location for hours and hours when you're
doing it again and again and again and
again then you're gonna get tired wires
are one option like in this shot from
apocalypse but they have their own
complications if you use wires all the
time sometimes you'll have sort of
pinching or an unnatural
um kind of uh you know angling so how
did hetta get everyone to look so steady
in this final shot without wires tiny
wooden blocks she brought blocks of all
sizes to the set the one she chose
varied based on the type of Footwear
on their own the blocks would be really
easy to spot
so had I covered them in non-reflective
black tape that way they could blend
into the shadow under an extra's foot
the best option is to cover up these
rigs with people and objects this moped
simply has its kickstand out but it was
blocked from the camera bikes and
scooters were a bit more difficult to
position as their kickstands are harder
to hide so had a built specialized metal
stands to hold them up straight to
appear as if they were mid-ride we had
to position something under one of the
pedals so that all of the weight could
be on the pedal hetta also had to teach
the extras how to position their bodies
for the scene to look realistic foremost
don't shift your weight because when
you're on a bike you just want to go
right you're used to being on a bike and
you treat it completely differently to
when you have to fake being on a bike
even when you use practical for these
sequences a final VFX assist is crucial
to put it all together to make it look
seamless the bike and foot rigs for
example were removed digitally in post
the same goes for those wires and poles
and Quicksilver scenes while animators
can stabilize real performances to get
rid of any moving and shaking digital
doubles give them much more control so
to get every detail just right Days of
Future Past and apocalypse recruited the
visual effects Studio Rising Sun
pictures for instance Rising Sun
Pictures created digital versions of
these students Quicksilver saves to
preserve the delicate balance of keeping
these characters Frozen in time but not
frozen in place that's also why they
created a CG version of this table for
Quicksilver to surf on we can use that
to interact with any effects that we're
creating like here when the animators
rebuilt a car digitally so they could
add slo-mo water splashing onto the
tires you can drive a car through and
that would work in the final shot but
it's the splash that you needed to sort
of slow down that you might not
necessarily get correct because once you
film something with that element in it
that's what you've got techniques like
facial replacement can fix continuity
errors as time slows down in Days of
Future Past Professor X yells oh
when they actually filmed it his mouth
was closed but contextually he would
have been more into his his word so his
original expression was swapped with one
where his mouth was wide open in any one
of these sequences there's the moment
when time resumes and everything goes
back to normal
since worst persons Frozen in Time
sequence ended back with Axel as he
poured coffee they only had to make a
single action return to normal but for
Days of Future Past they had to sort out
all the objects Magneto lifted into the
air alongside whatever positions
Quicksilver placed all these characters
in onset people and objects were tossed
around using wires and pressurized air
if that scene works and the timing works
as we get back into normal time then
we'll try and keep as much as we can but
only the objects within reason all these
bits of leftover food and extra plates
that land on the ground in the kitchen
and keep moving
big pizza dog who ended up becoming a
favorite on our crew so there was a
journey through uh the mansion that was
filmed with the cameras so there was
pizza dog with his jails sort of
flapping which was a CG head and here is
some slow moving footage where we've
we've taken various takes and so we
would mush that that Journey behind with
the motion blur and the speed so that it
feels like oh this is what it must be
like